when you encounter a story that you
personally are gripped by and surprised
by and have elements of transgression
subversion rebellion you have to trust
that reaction it's an instinctive
reaction to something that excites you
and immediately begins to stimulate
other thoughts other ideas images
insights curiosity is the big big part
of what I do is if I'm curious about
something and I get a story but I think
I'm kind of you know intrigued by all
captivated by what other questions am I
going to have all those questions
sustained two years of inquiry and
that's the basis under which I proceed
on a film is when I feel but I've got so
many questions I need to answer that got
to go ahead and do this the best example
would be the film man on wire which
immediately when I encountered that
story I was overjoyed and had a whole
set of emotions that just came flooding
in my red Philippe's bought his own
account of his walk upon the wire itself
I remember walking around the room in a
state of fear my palm is being wet just
by the description of being up on a
tightrope but that height in those
circumstances I remember of that
reaction was one that I trusted I think
we all know who work in the realm of
ideas when something is irresistible
when is it resistible you you can't
second-guess that that impulse going
back to your first impulse can keep you
going and keep you honest when
everything else got kind of complicated
and difficult and there are politics and
there are the usual you know kind of
conflicts you have many human activity
particularly filmmaking it would seem